ELIZABETH CHOE: Today is the
end of day four, it's Thursday.
Today is the day
that I'm feeling
the class sort of catching
up to my general well-being.
So today's the day that
has made me empathize
a lot with professors.
And it's made me think of
how the entire infrastructure
of teaching roles was
created in the first place.
It actually doesn't seem
very intuitive to me
to pair a researcher
and an instructor
and put it together
in the same role,
because they're really
different people.
I'm really sensing a lot of
trepidation and hesitation
in just trying creative ideas,
which I completely relate to.
But it's just so
incredibly striking to me
how everyone has this
mentality-- and not
just students in this class,
but every single student I've
worked with for
Science Out Loud--
that you have to measure 20,
30 times before you cut once,
and that as long as you
measure 20, 30 times,
you only have to cut once.
But the whole paradigm for
this production process
is almost the opposite.
You measure like three or four
times, and you cut 20 times.
You come up with like five
ideas and you write 20 scripts.
And there's just this
crippling hesitation,
this overwhelming
paralysis to just attempt
to write a script
that is so pervasive
through every single
student I've worked with,
including myself.
I'm also realizing that the
thing that students need
is concrete
examples, that people
can recognize big
concepts and not
be able to implement them
themselves successfully.
It takes a lot to become
self aware of your work,
essentially.
But I think today was good
because it gave the students
a chance to look at a script
that was written and storyboard
it and sort of unpack
what about it worked
and what didn't, and
sort of tie the bigger
concepts that we've been talking
about into a concrete example.
The next step that
they need to make
is being able to implement
that into their own work.
So we have the concepts
that we've established,
we give examples of what sort
of fit into those concepts
and what don't, and
then there needs
to be a third level of using
their work specifically,
to explain if their work fits
into those concepts or not.
I feel like each day
goes by so quickly,
but it's like a massive
amount of time that's passed.